Good morning
and welcome to day 5 at Reinvent.
I want to begin by thanking you for choosing
to spend your Friday morning with us.
I know you're a very passionate bunch. It
is the only possible explanation to spend
your Friday morning
listening to Web 3,
payment protocols, digital assets,
payments,
and agenting payment.
I don't know if I would have made it here, but I applaud
the curiosity.
In addition to being grateful,
I'm very excited today. I'm excited because
we're joined by our customer Coinbase,
who will also share their journey with
Agentic payments on AWS.
Before I begin,
I would like to understand a little bit about
the mix we have here in the audience. I
walked around and talked to some of you,
and seemed like some of you had some background on
Web 3 and some don't.
It'll help me understand who has, you know, the,
the mix of the crowd so I know how much time I can spend on
that. Can I see a show of hands?
How many of you are actually building actively
on Web 3?
OK, very few. So I will spend a
little bit of time giving an overview on web
3 and digital assets,
so you get a deeper understanding of the topics
that are set to follow.
OK, my name is Arvind,
and I will be jointly presenting this
session
with Joshua Smith,
senior solutions architect at AWS,
and Eric Rappel,
head of engineering Coinbase development platform
at Coinbase.
So what are we going to talk about today?
I'm gonna start by giving you an overview
of Web 3 as promised.
I will spend a little bit more time than I originally
planned to so I can set the stage for you
on what is Web 3,
how does AWS see it? What is our perspective
on Web 3, what are some of the workloads,
how do we address the requirements of these workloads,
and what do we have planned as we move forward.
We will then segue from there
into what digital assets can do
for payments
and why they matter.
After which Eric will come on stage and
talk to you about
X 402,
an open source payment protocol.
And that will be followed by Josh's
talk on how to implement
agentic payments on AWS leveraging
AWS's foundational capabilities.
With X402 that Eric
talked to you about prior to that
sound good to you?
OK, so that's what to expect from the session. This
is a 300 level session. So in addition to
the overview I'm about to give you for the
people who are curious,
we will get a little deeper into the code
and into the implementation.
All right, so,
web 3, what does web 3 at AWS look like?
What's our perspective?
When I say web 3,
how many of you immediately think cryptocurrency?
Now I see more hands go up,
right? For good reason.
Crypto has been
probably the most popular use case
over the last 10 years for web 3.
So when we say blockchain, when we say web 3.
People immediately think crypto.
I'm here to tell you that our view of
Web 3 extends far beyond
crypto.
There are a lot more use cases
that take advantage of the same
foundational principles that
underpin Web 3.
Crypto is just one of it.
There are many decentralized applications.
That take advantage of these different
technologies that we're going to touch on today.
Web 3 came about in response
to the perceived shortcomings of the
current internet infrastructure,
with the core tenet being
decentralization.
There are a variety of decentralized technologies
that need to come together for you to
operationalize a web 3 workload.
Blockchain networks,
decentralized storage networks,
virtual machines for smart contract execution.
So if you're thinking about an actual
use case or a workload,
say, to bring a digital asset to life, oftentimes
you're pulling together a lot of these decentralized
technologies.
To operationalize a single workload.
That's really how it all comes together, and
when you do that,
you have a lot of choices to make.
And we at AWS are here to
provide you with the prescriptive guidance you need.
To build these workloads and deploy them
at scale.
So when you think about building a web 3 product,
using decentralized technology
is not the goal.
It is just a means to an end.
At the end of the day, you're looking to build
the product.
So in many ways it's incumbent on us to make
sure we're providing you with the right building blocks
so you can take advantage of these technologies
and build the product you need.
We are in the business of providing these primitives
of these building blocks so you can build the Web 3
products.
We don't build the web 3 products for you.
You're doing that.
What we do
is bring all of these foundational technologies
and primitives so you can go and
operationalize these workloads.
But as you go about doing this,
taking all of these decentralized technologies and
building that web 3 product.
Can quite often look like the squiggly
curve you're seeing on the screen.
And that is so because you have a lot of choices
to make.
A lot of components to take advantage of
to pull together a single solution.
The most foundational choices you will make.
are around
first choosing the right.
Right foundation to build your products.
Are you gonna use a public
or a permission chain?
And are you going to use use a mix
of both,
which public protocol are you gonna choose? Are
you going to choose multiple different protocols?
And if you do that,
are you going to have to build interoperability?
And now if you're talking about assets,
are you going to, are you going to provide custodial
solutions or non-custodial solutions?
How are you going to handle your smart contract execution?
What kind of standards are you going to use there?
These are all topics that you may or may not be familiar
with, and these are a lot of different choices to
make. And once you've gone
past these foundational core components,
then you get into
other choices you have to make.
How are you going to handle
your blockchain data? How are you going to do the analytics?
There's on chain data. There's off chain data. How
are you going to bring it all together
to make the choices that you have to make when
you build your product?
How are you going to build your wallet? Are you going to build it?
Are are you gonna buy it?
And of course
if you're involved in the
digital assets business, are you gonna be an
issuer? Are, are you gonna take care of that yourself
or are you gonna, are you gonna leverage somebody else
to do that
and go off to build the product you
need so you can remove the heavy lifting from yourself?
These are very big choices to make because
they inform how the business
is gonna progress from there.
And this is where we come in.
With the approach that we have taken for web
3,
we take that squiggly curve you saw and
do our best to make it
that straight line you're seeing on your screen.
And we are doing that with our 3 foundational
pillars.
Manage services,
do it-yourself Web 3 solutions,
and a very robust partner ecosystem
that we have built around Web 3.
Let's start with managed services first.
If you're looking to build your own products
on AWS,
You could take advantage of all of the primitives,
all of the building blocks that we have today.
And operationalize your solutions. You
could do it all by yourself if you chose to do it.
It is a lot of work, but it's doable.
All you have to do is take advantage of some of the core
infrastructure.
Products that we have and we help you build it.
Now from an infrastructure perspective,
let's focus a little bit on on EC
2. I do have lambda and other logos
over there, but I'll take a minute to talk about EC-2
here. One
of the core tenets, as I talked about earlier, is decentralization.
Decentralization does not mean
you don't run on the cloud.
It only means you're decentralizing the
authority or the decision making.
Now when you're thinking about running nodes, blockchain
nodes on the cloud.
AWS
offers you
a certain assurance by default,
which is there is no operator
access to any customer content on any
nitro-based instance that's running on AWS.
So now if you step back and think about one of the
big things that probably drove
you to think about decentralization,
it's about that access to data. It's about the ownership.
And with AWS, if you're spinning up an
EC2 instance and running it
by default,
there is no mechanism for any AWS
operator to access your content.
So your content remains protected.
It is perhaps one of the best reasons
as to why you should run
your blockchain nodes on AWS.
There are other components as well from storage
and security. I'll touch a little bit on security now.
If you're building custody solutions, I highly
encourage you to think about specialized
capabilities that we have built
specifically to address these web 3 custody
solutions.
AWS Nitro Enclaves.
It's the foundational
foundational component
for confidential compute.
On these wallet solutions.
And if you're using enclaves, you're
perhaps using a key store
to bring your keys to decrypt them within
the enclave to manage the keys, assign your transactions.
We have products like AWS KMS
and cloud HSM
that allow you to do that.
And I'm more than happy to take questions about it after
the session
we can deep dive into what that looks like on
AWS.
I'm just leaving you
with some components and products to think about
as you as you start thinking about these specific
solutions.
In addition to managed services, we also provide
certain do it-yourself solutions.
These are not production grade, but these help you hit
the ground running.
We have built what's called AWS Blockchain
Node Runners. It's an open source project.
We have blueprints for several popular
protocols on node runners,
and this helps you
spin up your own blockchain nodes on AWS.
So if you're looking to self-manage your
nodes, if you're not using a provider to
do it for you,
you could directly use EC2 to
spin up your blockchain nodes on AWS,
and Node runners helps you do that.
It provides you with the blueprints, and
we continue to add popular protocols
to node runners.
So if there are protocols that you care about, you don't
see it in our report.
Talk to me. Send me a note.
We'll at it.
Right? Another solution is
around blockchain wallets.
We, we've been working with blockchain wallets
for 4 to 5 years now, so we,
we have a lot of knowledge on this. We have a lot of
expertise we have built.
And we have shared all of that.
We have workshops on blockchain wallets,
we have blogs, we have prescriptive
guidance, architecture guidance on how to build
wallets on AWS.
Another big program that we run
for Web 3 is the AWS public blockchain
data. We provide
blockchain data sets for free.
We choose the top blockchain protocols that
customers must ask for or care about. We
monitor the activity to see which protocols
we need to keep adding,
and we add datasets for free.
We've been able to do this through partners
over the years.
And as we move into 2026,
we're taking a minor shift in the approach and
we're gonna work directly with the foundations
to bring you data sets from the foundations
so you don't have to rely on any partner partner
products we'll provide it for free for
you and it'll be available through the AWS
public blockchain data set program.
Let's take a quick, quick look at these,
at these node runners. I have the QR code here for
those of you who care to
care to look at these blueprints. We have added support for
about 14 to 15 protocols. We'll
continue to add more.
As we go through next year, we're also going to be monitoring
how many more L2s are coming up.
And depending on where we see activity
and demand, we'll continue to add it here. It is an open
source project, so you're also welcome to contribute.
We now have support for all of these chains
that you're seeing on screen with our public blockchain
data. Uh, some of it
is available more natively and some through partners.
I do encourage you to look at the partner solutions too,
because if you're not building your own data analytics
solutions, the partners are providing the data
sets for free,
but they have fantastic products
that help you
take advantage of this data and
immediately start mining the data with their products.
So if you're not familiar with, which I think some of
you are not in the audience,
with how to handle on chain data, how to,
how to work with it.
They've already solved the problem for you, so I
highly encourage you to take a look at some of the partner
solutions.
The most recent data set we added is from Chronos,
um. We do see more
demand for more chains coming up,
so you should expect us to add more datasets
within the next year.
And that's the QR code for that as well.
Which brings me to partner solutions.
So regardless of what you're looking for,
whether it's blockchain infrastructure solutions,
wallet or custody solutions, data and analytic
solutions, these are all foundational pieces. There's a lot
more. I could open a blueprint and we could walk through
that. There's a lot more, but these are very
foundational and for each of these
we have vetted
and qualified several partners
who have solutions on AWS
which can help you stand up your,
your decentralized application very
quickly. Because
it takes care of all of the foundational base layers
for you, all you have to do is just focus
on that application you're looking to build for decentralized,
um, for decentralized technologies.
So let's take a quick look at top use
cases on web 3.
You know, I have a few here. They're not limited to
this. I just put it here because these are
where we see the most activity right now
tokenization,
trading, payments and wallets.
You're going to actually hear about tokenization payments
today in conjunction,
so I'm not, I'm not going to spend a lot of time
here, but what I want to leave you with
as a thought about Web 3
is one of the biggest trends that we're starting
to see emerge
is around digital assets,
tokenizing securities,
tokenizing currencies even.
Stable coins.
But all of this does not matter
if you don't have a use case downstream to actually
take take advantage of what is being provided
and that's where payment really comes in,
right? So think about one
as the enabler, the other as the actual
utility that's gonna that's
going to take this more mainstream as we move forward.
Here's an up close look at what a
tokenization
solution looks like.
And, and don't panic. I'm not gonna walk through the
solution. What I want to draw your attention
here is if you look at an end to end
tokenization solution
and you break down the building blocks of it,
you can quickly see
we have all the products and capabilities
to address each of those building blocks and AWS.
And I could just as easily map this
building block and show you how our partners
play over here who provides
the tokenization engine, who can provide a wallet,
who can provide the custody solutions
so the high level
idea I want you to take away from this
is not only
can we help you stand this up on your
own if you want to,
we could just as easily help you get moving
with partners as well.
So think about it as a blueprint that can map to AWS
or map to partners depending on your appetite
to build or buy.
Now let's take a look at the web 3 trends
that are shaping.
The ecosystem for us.
I have a few different bullets here, but I really
want to draw your attention to 2. That's what
we're going to focus on today.
There's been a lot of institutional government adoption
that we've started to see which has led to regulatory
clarity.
So if you're familiar with Genius Act, if you're familiar
with clarity itself,
you will know that stablecoins are starting
to get accepted more as
a digital asset that could be leveraged for
multiple different use cases, and we're seeing
more informed language from the governments on
this one. So we are hearing a
lot from our customers.
But like I said,
issuing a stable coin is one thing, but actually using
it is is what matters. That's what really
brings it to everybody and that's where payments
come in so stable coins and payments.
We're seeing it as one trend
together and you're gonna hear from
Eric and Josh today about
what we do with digital assets, how can you
actually build a payment solution,
which brings the next question
why does it matter? I already have currency.
I already have a payment solution. Why does this
all matter? It matters because
there are challenges with the existing traditional
payment solutions,
current payment solutions.
There's very high processing fees. There
are long settlement delays.
There's currency fluctuations to contend with.
Complex cross-border transactions
that need to happen if you're trying to move money from
one country to another.
And lastly, there's a lot of multiple intermediaries.
Take a step back and let's look at it from the other side,
right? If the processing fees are
really high,
it's really hard to do smaller transactions.
Digital assets payments actually reduces
the cost because there's less infrastructure
needed, less
fraud management costs,
automated compliance,
all of this actually reduces the cost,
which brings a big benefit
which is micro payments.
You could now be paying smaller payments.
You could be doing a lot more transactions,
right? Again, settlement delays
if you're trying to trade, say on Monday, you've
got to make sure you're transferring on Thursday,
the previous week,
to make sure the money is ready for you to use.
Now if you're a small business
and you're contending with 3 or 4 delays in transactions,
it really affects your cash flow.
Digital assets settle in minutes.
Improving cash flow, improving response time.
Same goes for currency fluctuations. I don't think I
need to elaborate on that. If you're dealing with currency
fluctuations and waiting for money to settle,
you could be losing 1 or 2% points if currency
is shifting.
And intermediaries, right,
if we remove the intermediaries, if we reduce the intermediaries,
not only does it get faster, it gets cheaper,
but more importantly, it reduces the counterparty
risk. So
there are a lot of advantages that are starting
to drive why digital assets
payments are going to become more mainstream.
The one thought I'll leave you with is this allows
us to bank the unbanked.
There are over 1.2 billion
people without access to actual banking systems
today in the world.
This brings banking to them.
This brings peer to peer transactions.
This brings a lot more that they can do.
I'm going to now invite Eric to come and talk to you
about X402 payment protocol and
how it enables digital assets payments.
Thank you for listening to me.
Thanks, Ivan. Um
Super excited to be here. This is the this is the first
time I've been at a silent disco
talk so if you're if you're in the audience and you can't
quite hear me, try the headphones,
um. So
I'm Eric. I lead engineering for Coinbase
developer platform.
CDP is kind of like
what AWS is to Amazon.
CDP is to Coinbase, so.
Amazon took all their expertise in
building
uh cloud infrastructure and
made that available to millions of businesses
to to leverage and use. Uh, CDP
has done the same with Coinbase's
infrastructure around custody of assets,
payments infrastructure, blockchain infrastructure,
wallets, orchestration, trading,
etc. There's a bunch of things
on the slide that we do that.
Are not even here. Like if you wanna talk
payments or stable coins or trading as a
service, uh, come and talk to me after
this. But we also have great wallets. We also have
great access to data products. We,
uh, also have nodes and staking and
on ramping and off-ramping and ramping into
the crypto ecosystem.
Um, but I'm not here to talk about CDP
today. I'm here to talk about agentic
payments and.
A project that we've been working on called X402.
Um, so broadly at Coinbase
we think that stablecoins are an
extremely compelling.
Technological solution for
AI
and so by a show of hands who in in the
audiences knows what a stablecoin is.
I guess, probably about 70% of people.
Um, maybe to level set, a stablecoin
is
a token
that exists on a blockchain
that's pegged 1 to 1 to some fiat asset.
So the one folks, uh,
most likely would have heard of in this room is USDC.
USDC was a,
uh, stablecoin launched by Circle and Coinbase
in partnership.
Uh, it's backed 1 to 1 by a mix
of US Treasuries and dollars
and bank accounts, and it's fully audited.
Both Circle and Coinbase are now public companies.
You can literally go see every Treasury
serial number that backs USDC and
know for a fact that it's backed 1 to 1.
So if you're holding one USDC,
you can get out $1 into
your bank account.
Um, Why
are stablecoins really good for agents? Well, there's,
there's a bunch of factors that I'll get into cost to transact,
speed of settlements,
um, but
there's kind of a more fundamental problem that you face
when you get into payments and that there are no
open standards for payments.
So let me hit you with a definition,
so. The Internet has existed
for coming up on 35
years roughly,
uh, and we don't have a standard for
payments.
If you want me to go really, really deep into
this point,
I did a talk on Wednesday on the FSI track
just basically breaking down standards
and the
reasoning why they're important, so I encourage
folks to go check out that recording.
Um,
but let me define what I, how
I think about Internet native payments, and so
I would define Internet native payments as a method for
computers to programmatically exchange
payment
in a standard and neutral way.
Within the existing client-server paradigm
that the internet is built on.
And without requiring a
human to be in the loop.
So what do I mean by standard and neutral?
It means that every interaction
between a client and a server should be the
same. We don't download a different
browser for every website that we visit.
The Internet works because
the browser that you use that's published by Google
can visit a website published by Amazon, and
there's an agreed upon standard way to
transmit that data,
those standards being
HTML, CSS, JavaScript
for interaction,
etc.
Neutral in that
it doesn't bias towards any particular
payment processor or blockchain
or mechanism of payment.
Any mechanism that wants to be represented within
an Internet native standard needs to be
able to represent their payment flows within that
standard
without gatekeeping.
And then within the existing client server
paradigm
for those of you who have integrated a payment API before, you'll
probably have noticed that at some point the client
usually will make a call out to someone else or
there's a web hook or there's
some component that
exists
outside of the
request the client is making to a server directly.
And then without requiring a human in the loop.
Almost all payments that have occurred on the internet up until
this point have been
downstream of a human entering a credit card on
a website.
And so if we believe that we're going
into an age of agents,
we need to break out of that paradigm.
And you see remnants of this idea that we
need an Internet native
mechanism for payments
all the way back into the 80s and 90s and
so. The HDP
1.1 standard,
uh, which I believe was published in 1997, reserved
an HDP status code, status code 402.
Uh, for
future use to represent payment
is required to access this resource.
In fact,
the Mark Andreessen, you know, co-creator of
Netscape,
spent a lot of time trying to make payments on the Internet
work, uh,
and, but the technology wasn't quite there,
and part of the reason we think the technology is there
now is the rise of stablecoins.
And so 5 years ago, back in 2020,
it cost about $10 to send a stablecoin.
But While
kind of the world was focused on AI and
many other things,
blockchains got extremely good.
And now it typically costs under
0.1 of a cent to send a stablecoin,
and that could be a single
dollar or that could be a million
dollars. But the actual cost
on chain
to send that money
is 0.10 cent.
And there's no percent base fee. You're purely
using, paying for the resources on
the blockchain that your transaction is utilizing.
It kind of breaks.
It's, it's unintuitive. Most people are used to, oh,
there'll be like a 30 cents fee and a
3% fee,
um, but with blockchains you're paying for
the processing power of the blockchain that you're actually utilizing.
And so as blockchains scale and
can do more throughput, can settle faster,
you can pass on those direct benefits
to payments.
So AI really forces us to reevaluate
Internet native payments.
AI is being used by hundreds of millions of people
every day now,
but the number of economic transactions
that they are performing are incredibly low.
And part of the reason for that is AI agents
are fundamentally
a program running on a computer. I'm not sure
how many of you have
written an AI agent, maybe a show of hands if you've
written an AI agent.
About maybe about a third of people,
uh, you will quickly realize when you
want to start building in an AI that AI is
not so different from a wild loop that just
runs for a long time that makes calls
to an LLM.
These agents have no fundamental,
no
way
to consistently transact.
You end up with these kind of walled gardens
if these gardens exist at all.
Uh, how many of you by show of hands has had an AI agent
pay for something for you on the Internet?
Probably with ACP or some other standard,
yeah, yeah,
so you're starting to see these standards emerge
to address this problem, and ACP is a great standard
for checkout and kind of human in the loop
conversational commerce, but I think if we want true
autonomy we need
the standards of payments to be built directly into the
internet. Because
AI agents really break the fundamental
economic model of the internet.
And so if you think about how a lot of
the internet works.
And has worked up until this point.
Some merchant is paying some
website. That website shows you
content and ads for the merchant.
You as a user consume that content and
that ad,
uh, and then at some point you convert
and you purchase a good from the merchant.
This is, you know, I'd say a lot of how the consumer
Internet works, and
the website is incentivized to publish
content because they can serve ads. Those ads convert.
The merchant pays. It's a nice closed loop between
three actors.
What we've seen is that AI removes
the ads and hence removes the payments
as more people start to use their chat interfaces
to consume the internet.
You probably haven't seen an ad from a
website that has informed a response from an
LLM
and scraping to train these LLMs also
results in value being missed by the content publishers
and so you break the circle
so we need a new circle we need a new economic model for
these kinds of interactions.
And one of the ways to do this is just
directly pay for the content.
Skip this loop,
directly pay the website.
And this is where we enter X402, which is
the open standard for internet native payments
that Coinbase has been working on.
And really what X402 is is a bridge
between the Internet
and the blockchain-based
payments.
It's very distracting to speak when people are clapping, um.
Bridge between the internet and blockchain based payments
and so you get the benefits of
blockchains and the benefits of.
These subcent transactions.
In the Internet,
part of the reason why it's not viable to pay
directly for content is because it's really hard to move
30 cents or 50 cents or $1.
With existing rails that
When fees are 30% to 3%.
As a business, if you're charging 50 cents, you're
now getting 14 cents in value,
which is a lot of margin to eat,
whereas if you're being charged 0.1 cents.
Well, now you're making 4050 cents or 49.9
cents, right?
And so what is X402?
X402 is an open standard for internet native
payments. It hits the points of the philosophy
I hit, I mentioned earlier in the
talk. It started at Coinbase. It was,
it was actually created by me.
Uh, and it's now being moved into an
independent foundation
structured as a Linux Foundation JDF.
So how does, how's it going?
So in November X402 performed 70
million transactions.
Uh The growth is pretty
startling, to be honest with you. We had this nice 30%
week over week growth chart and then
hit a huge inflection point in November where
it, it really took off.
And of those 70 million transactions,
the volume, the number of dollars
moved was actually
about $40 million.
And so you'll notice that that $40 million is less
than $70 million. The average transaction size
on X402 represented a
transaction of roughly 80 cents.
Uh, and those are transactions you couldn't really
do in card rails, and
you know X402 would let you scale up payments
anywhere from 1 cent to
a million dollars if you really cared to.
Um,
But that niche of kind of micropayments
has really been
the product market fit for X402
thus far and unlocked new things that
previously weren't possible.
So how does X402 actually work?
So
standard to the
existing flow of a client and a server, so a
client, a browser, your mobile phone,
an LLM, a bot
makes a HTP request
to a a server.
That server will then respond with a 402 status
code along with a header called payment
required
which contains a uh.
Contains data that conveys how to make the payment.
I'll get into what that data looks like in a second.
The client then says looks at that
header and then constructs a
a payload that represents that payment.
How that payment
payload gets constructed I'll touch on in a
minute. Don't worry, I'll get to it
and then remakes that same request
just with the header included in that request of
payment signature and then the payload
that they constructed.
The server
Now has an option.
It can do all the work that it's
doing on this slide
itself or for teams
that are less familiar with working in web 3,
you can delegate
the blockchain interactions in X402 to
what we call a facilitator.
And so facilitator has a fairly standardized
flow of.
The server will call to the facilitator
via HTP.
To an endpoint we call verify
and it'll propagate to it
both the payment requirements that sent the client
and the payment signature the client sent it, and
it'll ask the facilitator the question,
is this payment going to be valid? Should I actually
process this payment?
In the happy path, the facilitator will say 200
responses, yes, this is a good
payload. This will result in you
being paid. You should go and do the work
that's needed to respond to the client.
So this is where the server would do
its database queries, it's cache lookups,
generate a PDF, whatever it's doing
as a web server.
Uh, and then after it's done the work, it will
post to settle on a facilitator,
uh, again with that payment signature and that payment
required
data that it gave the client
and the facilitator will
handle submitting the transaction to a blockchain.
Once the blockchain blockchain transaction is
submitted,
the facilitator will respond back
to the server and say
this payment succeeded.
And this is actually a blocking operation.
With modern L2s and modern blockchains,
the processing time to confirm a transaction
is roughly 2 seconds,
and so you can actually know before you
return to the client,
I've received the money and it's not a reversible
transaction.
Stablecoin support
Refunds but not chargebacks
and so you as the as the server can always
say oh yeah I made a mistake I'm going
to refund to the client
but the client doesn't have the ability to take funds they've
already given to you away.
And so now that you have your funds, you can
return to the client and say, hey, here's here's that news
article, here's that API access that
you want. Uh, and you
do that through a standard HTP
through standard HTP verbs, and you can, it
works through the entire entirety of the HDP
spec just leveraging headers. You can return
to a post to
get it, put, whatever you want.
So let's get into that payment requirements, uh,
data structure. So this is the top
level of what payment requirements looks like.
You have a top level version for the X402
protocol.
Uh, we're about to release the V2 of the spec.
And then a list of.
Payment requirements that we call accepts,
so this accepts keyword allows the server
to specify multiple ways
of payment. So you as a server can
say I wanna, I support being
paid with USCC on base. I also support
being paid with USCT on
Solana.
And in the future we export 2 is
going to support fiat methods. You may even say
I support USD on Mastercard
or Visa.
Uh, and then an error
to convey error information to the client.
And so each one of those payment requirements
that in that accepts key is is
kind of exploded out here
and they consist of a scheme, a network,
an asset,
a pay to field,
and then max amount required,
which is the amount to be to be transferred. There's
other fields of metadata there, but those are
kind of the most important ones.
And so what this can look like is
you may return to the client something that looks like
what I have on the right
where we're operating on X402 version
one. We accept,
uh, the scheme exact
on base
of the asset that is the identifier
for USDC
and then I wanna be paid to
a crypto address and that crypto
address can be any wallet.
It could be
an exchange like Coinbase. It can be any.
Any address that is capable
of receiving.
Uh, crypto assets.
And then the, you didn't pay me, payment not
included. And
these
And so let's talk about the payment payload.
You'll notice scheme and network,
and the way to think about it is scheme is the logical
way that money moves.
And so in exact
it's the equivalent of me handing you a dollar.
That's as complex as the interaction is.
You've, I've taken $1 out of my wallet
and I've handed it to you.
You could have other logical ways of moving money, for
example, with LLM token generation,
you don't necessarily know how much to charge.
Until the generation of the the tokens
is complete
because LLMs don't deterministically
finish. And so you may, uh,
you can imagine a scheme that we'd call up to
which says, hey, I may charge you up to
$1
but I don't yet know exactly what you're going to be
billed and so
pre-authorize me $1 and then
after tokens are finished generating I'll
charge you based on the work that I actually
performed. And so
how you construct this payload
is what we call a mechanism,
and the mechanism is based on the top
of scheme and network. And what this that
means is that
the way you perform the payment
is decoupled from the network and the logical
way that payment is performed.
And so
exact on base Seulia
works differently than Exact does on Solana, for,
for example.
And you can optimize the payment flow
for the blockchain network or fiat network
where the funds are actually going to settle.
And so some of our goals for X402 were
safety, nativeness, ease of adoption,
and neutrality and extensibility.
And so on safety,
the client holds
the logic to construct the payment.
The server or the facilitator have no ability
to move funds without the client
authorizing the funds to move.
The server elects which payment mechanisms
it chooses to accept
and so someone can't say, hey, I
paid you on this obscure chain
now you owe me now you owe me your services.
The server dictates where which
mechanisms they choose to to accept, and
then the client chooses which one it wants
to use. Similarly to if you're at a point of sale,
it might accept Visa, Visa, Mastercard, Amex,
and cash.
You pull out your wallet, you say, Oh, I've got a Visa card. I'm
gonna pay with Visa.
And then the facilitator is not
in custody of funds at any point
and cannot direct funds and route
them in any way.
It is simply an abstraction over
the blockchain to make it so that servers don't
need to run hot wallets and run RPC nodes.
They can delegate that responsibility to a facilitator
that just manages gas and transacting with blockchains
at scale.
And so
safety for EVM Exact
specifically we use EIP 309
messages, which is a standard
in the EVM ecosystem for signature-based
transfer,
and the result is that the only way funds
can move is if the client has signed
an intent that the funds can move.
Nativeness. So
we want to include payments in
the existing communication that
occurs between a client and server. And so that
means that these types need to be represented in a way
that are native to the transport.
We also decouple transport from
how funds move in X402. And
so in HTP we include payment
requirements and payloads and headers.
In the existing requests that occur
in MCP, we include them in the
meta field
that exists in every MCP
interaction and tool call.
Then in A to A we include it in
the metadata X402
payment field,
uh, and we try to follow the conventions of each
transport that occur and you, this
is all standardized and documented in the repo.
Any person can write a client or
server independently of our reference
SDK that will be able to interact with any other
client and server because
how transport works is as
part of the standard so you can go
read the documentation on how
X402 works within the MCP context
and then write your own client or use
many clients that have been written over the last couple of months.
Ease of adoption, so.
Whenever possible, prevent the need for RPC
or gas on the client.
You shouldn't need to introduce
new technologies to a client's stack. We want as
much backwards compatibility with browsers
and the existing web ecosystem as
possible.
And then ensure all signatures and
standards and signers in our SDKs
adhere to industry standard interfaces.
This is a very like
in the weeds thing,
but if there's an existing pattern for
representing an action,
just use that. Don't invent new things.
Then we try to provide middleware for
all the common HTTP frameworks. So
if you use Express, Hono, Flask,
Jin, there's more here that I'm missing,
but you can integrate X402
into your existing service as a middleware
in one line of code.
And then I have
facilitators, as I've mentioned that abstract away crypto
and make it so that the barrier to adoption is incredibly
low. You don't need to learn how to operate a hot wallet.
You don't need a a node.
Facilitator, you just need a URL to
to make RPC requests to and
everything happens and
our middleware is extracted uh abstract that
away. You just
add the
facilitator URL you wanna use into your
middleware config.
Then extensibility neutrality. This is why
we decouple data structure from
implementation
so that EVM Exact can be different
than SVM Exact
and client and
clients and facilitators have a shared
understanding of what to do in that scenario.
Similarly to if an image tag is using.
PNG. Your server knows
how to encode that PNG and your browser knows how
to render that PNG.
And then we would prefer to be philosophically
we prefer to be
unopinionated and modular versus
trying to be full stack and solve every problem,
trying to solve one problem very well
and things like identity
and other aspects in the agentic system,
we wanna be compatible with those things, not try
to force everyone into our full stack
solution. And so what
does this give us?
Well, so this demo video I have here is
uh. Uh
me using my chat, uh,
my chat interface LLM
to research X402 and the trends about X402
that have been happening recently.
Uh, and what, what's unique about this chat interface
is it has
an MCP tool that gives it access to
a wallet with stablecoins.
Uh, the ability to pay for X402
resources
and the ability to discover
X402 resources
and so what you'll see is that
it first searches the web
to try to research X402
and then it checks what we call the bazaarre, which is the
marketplace for X402 services,
uh, and
pays for data from one
of those services to enrich the report that it
writes about X402 and these funds.
And this is the wallet that it has. These funds
are isolated to the agent.
It has 56 cents in its wallet. It only
can spend that 56 cents.
Then I have the ability to set permissions
on how much you can spend per request or in a
session. And anyone can build this
experience. This is entirely built off of
open standards like X402
and the wallet ecosystem and
infrastructure that exists
around stablecoins.
Uh, this, this
experience works on anything that accepts X402.
And so if your API accepts X402
payment. This MCP can
now pay you for your content.
Um
And that's pretty powerful I think it unlocks a
level of agentic
use
that hasn't previously been possible. Right now
you need to integrate each MCP tool manually.
Now you integrate one MCP tool and it
can pay for anything in an ecosystem
and what you get is dynamic agents
where the set of capabilities that they have
aren't limited
to a set of vertical integrations
and walled gardens that you as a human have
taken and integrated one by one
just like your browser can visit any.
Website on the internet, your agent can now pay
for any tool or service to make it better doing
work for you.
So now I'm gonna pass it off to Josh.
Uh, Josh is gonna show you some solutions
on how to use X402 and stablecoins
to build, uh, payment
infrastructure on AWS.
Right down. All
right, thank, thank you, Eric.
So let's start at a high level
conceptually, right? Um, we like
to think of a stack for building scalable
AI payment systems here at AWS.
A stack starts with a platform
or a foundation.
And AWS, as Arvin was talking about earlier,
provides primitives like EC2 for compute
or Amazon Bedrock for AI
or security primitives like Nitro Enclaves
or Edge services like Cloudfront. And today we're going to talk
through some of these foundations powering
the stack
and how to actually build solutions.
So on top of this, we leverage open protocols,
like Eric talked about, right? So some of these have been
around for ages, HTTP, DNS, HTML,
languages, frameworks, protocols,
and now X402 is an open standard
for payment that we can integrate into this and start
to use it. From here
we can start to combine platforms, protocols,
and build and enhance more advanced
services,
right? So this is middleware, some of these are
services as products, B2B products,
and so Amazon provides services
like Bedrock.
Um, we provide Agent Core for Bedrock, which I'm gonna talk
about in a moment, and we have this whole suite
for gentic AI.
Coinbase provides
what they call Agent kit, and Agent kit is
a tool to connect a wallet to
an AI agent, and we're going to leverage that today as well.
And lastly, all of this enables
us to build complex solutions
to connect to web 2 applications,
web 3 applications, hybrid
applications, and agent to agent communication
that involve payment.
So if we start zoomed out, um, I'm not going to
spend a ton of time on this slide, but AWS
provides agentic AI solutions
across the entire stack,
right? So we have infrastructure at
the bottom layer, we have development and services
for builders, and we have applications.
We provide this suite of models,
tools, applications, and expertise
that can help you get started on your journey in the way that
you want to do that.
We also provide robust infrastructure that
includes custom silicon,
data access, and other foundational services.
And today I'm going to zoom in just
this middle layer and bedrock because we're talking about
builders and we're talking about adopting these new
protocols.
So Amazon Bedrock, just to, as
a prerequisite before we go into this, is a serverless
and fully managed service
that helps you build, deploy and operate
Gen AI applications,
including agents.
Bedrock
provides access to leading foundation models from
Mistral, Anthropic, Cohere,
Amazon, and more,
and you can apply guardrails, optimize for cost, optimize
for latency,
leverage your data very easily.
We can use these features for any type of use case,
right, including building and operating crypto native
agentic AI payment systems.
Betteric also includes Agent Corp.
And so we have these services along the
top.
These are
services to deploy and operate agents securely
at scale, right? You can think of this top layer as
sort of operationalized and running those agents.
So we have run time, which is a serverless
runtime for long running
agents where you don't have to manage the infrastructure for
them. Then we have Agent Corp Gateway.
Which allows you to easily integrate MCP
servers, APIs with your agents and provide an
easy way to empower them with a
large array of tools.
And we're gonna use
both of these services today.
And then lastly,
Agent Core browser and code interpreter
um allow your agent to act autonomously in the browser
and to execute a code on your own terms.
On the bottom layer, I think of this as
sort of supporting tools, right, that enable these
agents.
Um, you need identity to build enterprise ready
agents with standard-based authentication. You
use things like OAth with your agents.
Agent core memory
allows your agent to store and retrieve short-term and
long-term memory for your agents because these agents
are stateless, running in runtime.
And we're also going to use this today, right?
And then lastly, observability helps centralize
your observability stack for Gen AI.
Agents, um,
especially payment systems,
accuracy and the lack of determinism
in LLMs makes observability
has to have an extra layer in there.
So when we use these tools,
um, if we zoom out here, what can we accomplish
here? Well, one of the key areas we see
in the maturity of AI
is the ability to discover and use
tools, right? So an agent isn't,
this could be tens of thousands of tools at the end of the
day. So Agent Core Gateway plugs into
this ecosystem,
allows for tool discovery, paired with
Auth to say which tools can which agents use,
and then we can start to leverage tools which
can be paid API keys. Maybe you have an
existing relationship, a monthly subscription where you
have an API key.
You maybe you have internal services running on a
lambda function or AC2 server that you wanna
call, but what we're gonna talk about
today is this middle channel.
Maybe you want the ability for your
agents to discover and use tools
in the way that Eric showed in his video
to say,
you know, go see what's available on
the Internet, go see what I can use X42
to accomplish my goals, right?
So we can take an architecture where we have cloud
front, we use lambda edge to allow that to run
functions,
and we have content backed by S3 or
EC2,
and we can create this um framework.
So today
I'm gonna talk about.
An example of a travel agent AI
and the data providers that work with it.
So, um, this could be built by a company,
you know, we have a hypothetical company looking to serve
customers
that are building automated vacation packages,
let's say, right? So the agent
presents a front end
to the user,
uh, which is the travel agent AI interface, the
chat, and the AI can then use Agent
Core Gateway to go and discover available
tools from an X402 MCP
server. So
as examples here,
right, this agent is going to need a lot of different types of data.
It might, it might need to leverage
a global distribution system that has hotel inventory,
flights, flight prices, availability, seat availability,
and more. This may result, this may
charge in a variety of ways. They could be per query,
booking fees or challenges.
It also might need points of interest, databases,
local attractions, um, these could be per
query, right? Send me the review for this restaurant
for a penny,
um, this could be weather data to identify
delay risks or forecast
or just check if you wanna go somewhere sunny,
right? So
We'll start zoomed out. This is the end
to end architecture.
So in the left side we have the
travel agent AI
and this is going to be powered by a server wallet
using nitro enclaves from
Coinbase,
and agent kit from Coinbase that's interacting
with our Bedrock AI agent.
In the middle, we have our data provider or merchant.
They're going to be providing the API or the
weather data map services,
and then we have the rails, which is that facilitation
layer that Eric was talking about.
Since we're going to do crypto data payments, we just look
at the foundation first, right, secure wallets
using the giant enclaves.
Um, I'm not going to
spend a long time here, but we do have a blog written
with Coinbase on our AWS site,
um, which I can, I can send or share.
We might have, we have a QR at the end with that.
Um, but this is the architecture Coinbase uses
on AWS to power their server wallet.
Um, when a developer wants to create a wallet or sign
a transaction,
it's going to follow this workflow through the API
gateway. The request is passed to a secure signer
inside of this enclave,
and neither Coinbase or AWS operators
can access those keys.
This wallet provides a secure foundation
for us to build and enable crypto payments.
Now we just have to connect to it.
So Agent Kit
works with the Bedrock AI agent.
And this is the architecture we're gonna talk about today.
This is the architecture powering
that AI agent,
and it uses Agent Kit to access that secure
wallet. So you see Agent Kit here on the right side,
uh, in that gateway,
but, but starting up here,
um, there's a supervisor agent,
and this could be any multi-agent workflow, this is just
an example. We have a supervisor agent
running in Agent Corp run time.
And it's going to interact with an itinerary
agent that manages the memory and planning for the
travel, and it's going to make assumptions. It's
going to say
we need to find a hotel in this place because we've
confirmed that place is good, right? We want to go there, so
we want to confirm that we have availability.
So it's going to run those assumptions by the tool agent.
The tool agent is going to use AG Core Gateway.
To
look through its available tools. Some of these tools
might be directly registered with Agent Core Gateway,
but there might be external MCP
servers outside of the account,
right? This could be X42 MCP servers
or maybe even some kind of universal
travel MCP server run by an existing
travel company or travel agency.
So if we look at the end to end path, the tool
agent is going to
call Agent Core Gateway. It's going to
call the X42MCP server
through Agent Core Gateway, and then it's going to
access the data it needs, and it's going to pay for it via
X42, and it's going to be able to leverage
the wallet that it has
through Agent Kit, which is also registered to the gateway.
So that's the AI agent
side, but we can actually go look at
the other side on AWS, right? If
you are a data provider, let's say you're the service that's
providing that weather data, that's providing that map
data. Remember, these
are the entities that are providing the flight scheduling,
the distribution.
There is an opportunity for these,
these customers on AWS to also
start to monetize their data in new ways for
new workflows and
not rely on
existing bundled and subscription ways to pay
for those services.
Using the bridge bridge of X402.
So just to put our position on the
map here, this is the architecture from the other
perspective. We have some overlap with Agent Corp
gateway. We see the same X402
MCP server that we saw previously.
Um, this is just to place us. So it
has the
agent kit and the X402 MCP server
registered as a tool.
Once this passes through that layer,
Um, it's going to go through the CDN,
which is cloud front,
and it's going to go to a lambda function
that we have here, lambda edge,
as a viewer request, right?
And this viewer request is going to,
it, it may initially not have payment
information. So this lambda function
is going to send back requests
saying, hey, this content actually has to
be paid for,
right? So where you need the header that
shows that it needs to paid for, it's going to specify
the asset,
the network,
up to parameters like Eric was talking about, and the
client can retry the request.
If the payment header
is present, it's going to ask the
facilitator
to verify.
It's going to say, hey, is this payment going to work?
Is this payment going to go through?
Is this address valid?
If that's valid,
the X42 function can respond back to
the server and make the request.
And then ultimately it can,
the, the, the agent can
issue the correct payment.
At the end of the workflow, it can forward the request back to the
origin, in this case our EC2 web server
that hosts the satellite weather images or JSON
weather data or whatever data the travel agent needs.
And at this point, the agent has requested weather
data. It has been paid for
by their connected wallet via agent Kit,
and the merchant has been prompted for the
accepted payment
via the X
has prompted for it and then received the accepted payment over
X402 into their own wallet.
Facilitator handles the settlement
and on the blockchain, and the funds arrive in the crypto
wallet of the merchant.
So We also have some
additional resources, blogs, things like that,
um, the agent core docs
will show you what I was talking about earlier about observability,
identity,
um, runtime gateway, and you can get familiar
with those primitives. We also have a blog
that we've jointly written with Coinbase going in deep
into the, um,
the nitro enclaves-based wallet that we used,
and we have a link here to CDP's documentation.
This covers X402, Agent
among other other services that they offer.
And with that, thank you so much for your time I hope
you enjoyed the talk and uh have a good rest of your weekend.